who should pay on the first
date men I'd want him to be like just
taking action being a man I guess being
the leader yeah no not really the leader
but just being a man and stepping up
anday being the man stepping up doing
his manly stepping up and not being the
leader we're going to take a look at uh
some videos these are all videos having
to do with gender roles so let's uh
let's go to the first video the sad
thing is a lot of these stereotypes
actually come from sexist beliefs
because there is no biological
difference between males and females
that indicates whether or not they can
drive or cook well these stereotypes are
exclusively because of the beliefs that
people have had in the past about gender
roles there are
boring in reality such as the idea that
men are stronger this can still be
really toxic and sexist and is not
always true but biologically men tend to
find it easier to build muscle because
of their hormones therefore making them
often stronger men can cook and clean
women can drive and as for child care
some people like make the argument that
breastfeeding is a biological difference
but that kind of stops after the age too
so men can look after children too you
can do whatever you want gender doesn't
really matter it's sexist you like how
she she has to admit oh there are some
stereotypes that are correct like men
are stronger that's not a stereotype by
the way it's not a stereotype that men
are stronger it's just it's just a it's
a it's a reality it's a thing I'm
stronger I'm
smarter I'm better but even then so she
has to begrudgingly admit that but she
puts it in scare quotes are stronger
quote unquote stronger no men are not
quote unquote stronger we just are
stronger the rest of it that she
mentions like some some of those uh
stereotype that that men can't cook
that's not even a stereotype that's who
who actually thinks that in fact most of
the top chefs in the world are men so
I'll take that yeah you're right
actually you know what men men men can
cook and we're better at it I mean that
seems to what you're saying so I I'll
take that congratulations you played
yourself what was the other one this
this stereotypes of uh of men and women
oh men women can't drive I think that
there is some probably some biological
basis to that I mean there need need to
be more research done done on it I don't
want to be involved in the research
because it' be it's very dangerous uh to
be in a car with a woman while she's
driving but I think that there's
probably an hand eye coordination there
other things you know it's a trend that
we've noticed and there's probably a
reason for the trend but you have to be
willing to to investigate it and when it
comes to something like driving you know
that is uh it's all it's hand ey
coordination it's Focus it's a very it's
a very physical thing I turn now good
luck everybody
[Applause]
else and so if men tend to be better at
it there probably is a biologically
ingrained reason but a lot of these
things we can't even you can't even
research them or look too much into them
because then it's automat it'll offend
people like this most stereotypes and
I'm not going to say all but with most
stereotypes and this goes for gender
stereotypes goes for pretty much all
stereotypes they are not proscriptive
they are descriptive okay it is society
noticing things about groups of people
and commenting on it and that's where
the stereotypes come from nothing to cry
about I've got a holiday gift idea
that's sure to make you the hero of the
season now we all know the holidays
could be a bit hectic the shopping the
cooking the never ending list of things
to do but fear it out because I've
discovered a gift that's not just
thoughtful it's downright transformative
the gift of genu cell skincare from now
until Christmas genell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
my listeners at genucell.com Walsh YT
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skin care in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles Fine
Lines skin redness and yes even a
sagging jawline will disappear right
before your eyes with genus cell's most
popular collection genus cell promises
immediate effects you'll see results in
less than 12 hours guaranteed or your
money back G cell sent down a ton of
products for the entire office uh can't
even put into words just how much better
their faces look because of genus cell a
lot of improvement could still be done
there but genell you know there's some
things can't be fixed everyone discusss
me a little bit less now it's like
Christmas came early you deserve to look
and feel your best this holiday season
go to jal.com Walsh YT to get this
incredible holiday discount every order
today is instantly upgraded to free
express shipping that's genu sal.com
walshy today the same people that say
men and women have to be a specific way
or the same people who say that gender
is not a social construct when they are
and I'm sure that the Insight will be
quite profound and um indeed insightful
be but what does that have to do with
religion well a whole hell of a lot
because they're basing what a man and a
woman should be and how we should all
act based upon what they think their God
says men should act this way women
should act this way women should be
subservient to men this is how God
decrees it so you can see that these
things tie in together very well whereas
the rest of us see that these things are
just made up by each other and it
doesn't really matter act how you want
to act you don't have to be lock step
with anybody else gender is just really
made up stuff yeah my religion says put
a shirt on oh my God put on a shirt it's
disgusting we don't need to see all that
gender is made up he says and you know
he's actually right so he's he's 100%
right but but he doesn't real like he's
right in ways that he doesn't understand
uh gender is made up it's a madeup
concept made up by people like him and
by his side of the ideological divide
and we don't need it I don't need it I
don't need it it almost seems that there
could be a agreement here and there
never will be because these people don't
don't know what they're talking about
they don't even know what they want or
what they're saying what do you want
what do you want but um if if their
words had any meaning then we we would
almost be able to agree on this topic
let's just get rid of gender we we don't
need it we don't need it as a concept we
have sex male and female man and woman
and that's all we need that that's as
far far as this goes we don't need this
second thing that that accompanies it
and no one can figure out exactly like
what do what does this mean exactly what
do we need this for I don't see the
point so much of the confusion that the
left has when it comes to quote unquote
gender is that they've made up all these
Concepts and they're they're constantly
trying to figure out what they're
supposed to do with these Concepts that
they've made up so they make up all
these things and then and then they look
at it and say what am I supposed to do
with this they come up with all these
sloppy incoherent concept Concepts and
then they are confused by them
themselves and then they try to throw
that at us as if we're responsible for
it hold on this whole operation was your
idea uh so if you're trying to figure
out what to do what to do with gender
that's not my problem I don't need it
you know it's let's just get rid of it
we have sex male and female that's all
we have that's all you need that's what
we have we don't need this second thing
keeps it much simpler uh that'll do it
we'll end it there talk to you tomorrow
God speak I'm a girl and by me that's
only great I am proud that my Silhouette
is curvy that I walk with a sweet and
girlish gate with my hips kind
Andy